This is how Americans greet winter.
State highway departments demonstrate their latest snowplow techniques...
...and their mountain of salt for deicing roads.
Snowplow drivers show how cumbersome it is to drive a plow...
...and reflect on 2010's extreme weather.
Lots of snow.
There's too much snow.
In February, more than 50 centimeters of new snow,...
...fell on top of 90 centimeters of snow from a few days earlier.
On the other side of the globe, snow shut down Beijing,...
...with temperatures as low as minus 16 degrees Celsius.
But while Washington and Beijing dug out in winter, others sweated it out later in the summer.
First in Washington, stifling summer heat.
It's excruciatingly hot out here and all I wanna do is keep cool.
I'm looking for the nearest pool but I'll take a sprinkler at anytime.
Earlier in June, 32 degrees Celsius, in Moscow!
Children have gotten tired from the frost. They are enjoying the sun.
A month later in Russia, forest fires...
...and mass evacuations.
August in China, mudslides and torrential rains.
There are probably eight people buried underneath at this site.
In Pakistan, devastating floods put a fifth of the country underwater.